was there something that was bothering
him that he especially
thought he could contribute or work on
well of course we can't go back and talk
to him but we do have these student
notebooks there's two of them
one's called the philosophical questions
and the other is called the waste book
the philosophical questions has
discussions of the nature of reality and
various issues concerning it and the
wastebook has things that have to do
with motion in various ways what happens
in
collisions and things of that sort and
it's a complicated story but what's
among the things that i think are
interesting is he took notes
in the philosophical questions on stuff
that was traditionally
uh
given to you in the curriculums going
back several hundred years namely on
what
scholars refer to as scholastic or
neo-scholastic ways of thinking about
the world
dating back to the reformulation of
aristotle in the middle ages by thomas
aquinas in the church this is a totally
different way of thinking about things
which actually connects to something we
were saying a moment ago for instance um
uh
so i'm wearing a blue shirt
and
i will sometimes ask students where is
the
blue and they'll usually say what's in
your shirt
and then some they'll get clear and
they'll say well no you know light is
striking it photons are re-emitted they
strike the back of your retina and etc
etc and i said yes
you what that means is that the blue
is actually
an artifact of our perceptual system
considered as
the percept of blue
it's not out there it's in here yeah
right that's not how things were thought
about
well into the 16th century
the general notion
dating back even to aristotelian
antiquity and formalized by the 12th
century
at the paris
oxford and elsewhere is that qualities
are there in the world
they're not in us
we have senses and our senses can be
wrong
you know you could go blind things like
that
but if they're working properly you get
the actual qualities of the world now
that break
which is
occurring towards the end of the 16th
century and is most visible in descartes
is the break between conceiving
that the qualities of the world are very
different
from the qualities that we perceive
that in fact the qualities of the world
consist almost entirely in shapes
of various kinds and
maybe hard particles or whatever
but
not colors not sounds
not smells
not softness and hardness they're not in
the world they're in us
that break newton is picking up
as he reads descartes he's going to
disagree with a lot in descartes but
that break
he is
among other things picking up very
strongly and that underlies a lot
of the way he works later on when he
becomes skeptical of the evidence
provided by the senses
yeah that's that's actually i don't know
the way you're describing is so powerful
this makes makes me realize how
liberating that is as a as a scientist
as somebody who's trying to understand
reality
that our senses is just
our senses are not to be trusted
that reality is to be investigated
through
tools that are beyond our senses yes
or that improve our sense improve our
senses
in some ways
um that's pretty powerful for i mean
that is uh
for a human being
that's like einstein level
for be for a human being to realize you
can't tr i can't trust my own senses at
that time
that's pretty trippy
you